hey gang it's your old pals uncle hank
and kippy just want to thank you for
tuning in to ru garbage
yeah guys make sure you subscribe that
way you get the episode as they come out
you can also go to gasdigitalnetwork.com
use promo code ayg
to get bonus content and get the
episodes before they come out and hd
streaming
do it yeah welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast come on
this is are you garbage the show where
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and find out if they go up classy or if
they're a big old piece of [ __ ] and we
got two of them in studio today
i'm your host h foley coming at you on a
beautiful fall day here in the east
village
the leaves are falling i can taste the
[ __ ] reese's cup
now not long now baby halloween right
around the corner that's in like
48 hours what are you talking about and
i can't wait
my uh co-host is coming at you from
across the table which means today
is a fan question episode a family up
baby
family yep we know it's your guys
favorites gang let me tell you something
this guy was a candy bar he would be
a kippy bark okay and he would have dark
chocolate and a really soft center
and real bad eyebrows do me a favor give
it up for my best friend
kevin james hey what's up everybody
thanks for tuning in stop looking at
yourself in the monitor uh
i'm looking at you to make jokes you
look like you look like one of those
trash bags that people fill up with
leaves with the
with the jack-o'-lantern face on it that
they put out in front of their house
yeah
that's what you look like happy to be
here everybody
thanks for tuning in a little bit of
news coming at you today folks
um i you you know we just got to get
into it right
sure quick real quick real quick you
know guys uh
are you garbage we'll be leaving gas
digital network
um it's all dylan's fault blame dylan i
told you about those [ __ ] drops
huh i told you about the drops didn't i
i didn't [ __ ] listen man
you know people are actually gonna
believe that that's the worst [ __ ]
part it's terrible
no uh yeah guys so we're gonna go off
and do our own thing and uh we launched
a patreon you can check that out at
patreon.com
are you garbage uh i don't know if
that's
we're contractually allowed to talk
about that on the podcast we need the
money
he's got us up to our eyeballs in a
[ __ ] penthouse a minute in midtown
listen kippy uh kippy schultz over here
kippy was doing a little boozing this
weekend made a couple of bad business
decisions
and now the kids got a lease and they're
out on our own i don't know what the
[ __ ] gonna happen
we're gonna be broadcasting from the new
clean living studios somewhere in
midtown manhattan uh we're going out on
our own we cannot thank
uh gas digital enough yeah dylan of
course our [ __ ] producer has been
with us to the end
dylan g mike mike of course everybody
here louis ralph obviously
bobby shannon alex eric everybody the
whole gang
it's been awesome uh there's no bad
blood no bad blood at all and that's
what's that's what's [ __ ] so
awesome about about this networking
about lewis and all that stuff
and let me tell you this so we got to be
a part of uh of legion of skanks last
night it was the big guy the big
don't talk about it i'm not but it was
the big ari shafir trial
and just the production quality the
[ __ ] production
the [ __ ] the effort and energy that's
put into
to what they do and what they did
yesterday was
the exact reason almost that you know we
want to go out
and and yeah we want to build i want to
emulate what what these guys are doing
and
you guys have all been so supportive um
and the and the audience and the fan
base has grown so much that we want to
be able to give you know
the best thing that we possibly can and
do and do it for ourselves
yeah you know what i mean so that's uh
so that's why we're moving on that's the
that's the whole reason
it's not dylan's drops okay about ten
percent of it
it's not that he [ __ ] tried to put
the moves on my cousin the last time he
was down in philly
uh he's a good looking kid your cousin
that is
yeah guys thank you so much wait like i
mean everybody's all this gang fan
everybody's been [ __ ] fantastic
unbelievable we love everybody best fans
in the [ __ ] world
and we hope to god that you guys all
come with this space journey
we need you to come with us on this
journey all right there's a there's a
[ __ ] nut we gotta cover every month
now
yikes yikes um but yeah guys it's
exciting it's exciting we're really
excited
uh the response so far has been
fantastic so uh we're happy to see what
happens
and also too something that we want to
emulate is they do you know they do so
much
you know extra content they give so much
extra to their fan base
you know that's something that we want
to be able to do completely on you know
unlimited and unhinged
as far as you know just you know it's
not just going to be the podcast it's
going to be a whole shitload of [ __ ]
content and
it's going to be really really fun and
uh we really appreciate you guys
also too now all of the all of our
episodes all the way back to the first
episode that we've ever done ever are
now available on itunes spotify youtube
wherever you listen or watch
um that's where everything is and we're
still gonna do the two episodes for
everybody
every week to go out on itunes for free
to everybody we're just doing additional
episodes
some videos some other content some live
streams and stuff like that on uh
www.patreon.com
are you garbage check it out i need this
i don't think they
don't think they care it's not a secret
i know i'm it's a bit come on there
trash bag
jackal please
everybody hits i'm sick of hearing this
[ __ ] believe me i heard
it hurts me ah buddy but no again i mean
this you know
you know ralph and louis you know and
people like that
in this business are the people that are
showing people the way
the future is going to be also we just
want to be we want to be a part of that
on you know you know with us i i was a
little contact you guys
i was a little nervous coming in here i
thought it was going to be a [ __ ]
setup i thought i was going to come in
and have to
[ __ ] the puerto rican rattlesnake was
going to have me in an arm bar
gee mike's got a luger and a silencer
this is like that scene in the glorious
basketball look at all the plastic
you guys painting
all right guys um yeah thank you so much
good stuff we're excited man
yeah thank you and this is a family
episode baby this is the the going away
party it's gonna be a lot of family
things coming up so
get ready get your trashiest dishes
ready in recipes yeah that's at
www.patreon.com
got the tapes uh guys uh
i mean we've had [ __ ] when we put out
that we're doing a fan question episode
a listener episode listener question
episode
they [ __ ] fly in the kids go nuts i
announced it
i announced it like [ __ ] four hours
give it away we got we got
a d on who get you thanks man you have
to do that
thank you buddy that's [ __ ] dosed for
sure dude
why does the coffee here always have so
much froth i don't know
it has weight i always think it's a
cappuccino they're staring it with
darwin
it's just iced tea um thank you buddy
i hope it's toasty kidding me yeah
you're dressed for it
[ __ ] you're dressed like john candy
in every movie after [ __ ] 2004.
ah he really let it ride yeah he's like
i'm doing my own wardrobe
he leaned into it man i love it um
okay uh let's see we got some cues
we got some [ __ ] cues and i mean
they're [ __ ]
some of them are some of them are so
funny and i like i get jealous when i
see them some of them i have on my list
already that i'm like [ __ ]
before i could get to it you all think i
like that's what i know we're all
[ __ ] trash
um thank first of all thank you so much
to all the listeners that write in it's
[ __ ] and we just can't get to all of
them
you know and some of them are repeats
that we've done before so you don't want
to you know
the uh the facebook group has been
killing me lately
i've been dying check out the facebook
group check out uh you know
reddit and discord they're all you know
we're everywhere did you see the
spaghettios and lobster shells
oh yeah that's got foley family written
all over i'll tell you what looked
really good with the
was the hot dog the franken beans tacos
or tortillas
somebody whipped up they looked oh yeah
yeah but
i think that that was like that guy's
dinner that's an okay drunk thing if you
gotta pull it together but if you're
making that for a sit down didn't do it
like that on thanksgiving what are you
talking about
yeah all right let's get into it talk to
me this is one that i've been wanting to
talk
you know i've been wanting to bring up i
just waiting for the right guest and i
definitely we've talked about a little
bit you definitely have an opinion on it
and this is from my favorite [ __ ]
name charlene it's this book
charlene charlene no way [ __ ]
charlene kid
i'll do charlene you gotta be garbage
i'm down there with charlene in the
[ __ ] park that's such a name that you
know some boston skeezer throws out
[ __ ] charlene
i was also the only like every love song
in the 50s charlie
yeah there's a lot of charlene's running
around back there
charlie
um all right this is from charlene how
do you like your eggs
is one style more garbage than another
well i know what you're gonna say is the
trashiest what and my favorite and every
time
i like dylan bracing himself when i open
my mouth i like to cook mine in a shoe
from time to time
an old work boot if my dad had a long
day no but what would be the trashiest
and the most delicious is the dippy egg
oh what i'm a [ __ ]
are you a dippy kid yeah i grew up as a
fried egg over
like i don't know i don't know the name
technically it's over easy
is what a is what a dippy egg is okay
now a fried egg
means that you do it in a little bit
higher heat both sides so it really
seals sometimes yeah yeah
you can or you could do it sunny side up
and still be a fried egg fried eggs i
mean
yeah no i know what a fried egg is but
it gets you like over soft over medium
over my bowl i like when they're cooked
loose and soft i don't like them i don't
like when i don't like brown on my
omelette
okay i'll tell you that right now run
mine through again
do it again okay do it again um i was a
big friday kid all growing up
love a good yolk sunny side up does me a
little weird i just
i i don't like singing sonny's man if
you're doing sunnies you were either you
either did time or you were a nam
sunny side egg guys are [ __ ] crazy
yeah it's black coffee and grapefruit
juice
that's what comes with this [ __ ] two
sunny side up burn the hash browns
oh dude anything better than a burn set
of [ __ ] home fries from
me two weeks old from a diner good night
i used to love working in [ __ ]
breakfast places yeah coming up to the
coming up to the the restaurant industry
i mean
shout out to the bluebell grill and deli
you've took you've taken me there before
have i yeah after that horrible
corporate gig we did
oh no that was gems that was jim's
flashback to the 50s you used to work
there though i used to work there
is there is there any [ __ ] is there
any trash dining establishment you
didn't work out in blue belt
pennsylvania throughout the [ __ ] 80s
and 90s every time i ride by with this
kitty hey see there i used to bust
tables there i used to be a short order
cooked there i either i either
i was either cutting lawns uh working at
a gas station working in a restaurant in
the back
i wasn't really a front of the house
kind of back oh how
or my favorite job of all time coming up
was uh
was i worked at a car wash i could i if
if this goes south
you still have the bikini
number one washer holding up the round
cards
come on in you're thinking you got an
arrow you're out front letting the girls
hang out
i dude i could work in a car wash man i
love clean cars and the way they operate
yeah it's also too i it doesn't seem
hectic to me hold on and i use the
brenner's tip remember ernst said grease
the guy
doing the cleaning in the beginning yeah
slipped that guy at five oh you could
have eaten off that steering wheel
um i did
[Music]
um i wanted to get back to the eggs a
little yeah yeah
[ __ ] i would say and now when i say
dippy
okay that's not just a preparation it's
also an ingredient
50 eggs when i was a kid is my dad would
make the egg
it would be like an overeasy egg he
would put a little bit of ketchup on it
and then he would cut them all up and
chop it all up and mix it all up yeah
oh that was like [ __ ] tuna tartare on
toast yeah
we did that we did the same thing piece
of we would do a piece of strowman's
shout out the shout out to the s family
for sure
showing up early in the morning with the
fresh breath dude strollman's
just the right [ __ ] toast on them yo
you get you get a fresh bag of bread at
the grocery store
it's like finding gold it ain't nothing
better and you know it strowman's king
dawg
not that [ __ ] queen [ __ ] [ __ ] we're
talking
king size you ever go to somebody's
house and they have the little loaf they
don't have the like the family size
ah what's your dad do again yo what the
[ __ ] what are you in a salad you got a
go bag
you gotta hit the bricks quick you're
not investing in a whole loaf of bread
you bought enough bread for three hours
what's going on here bro i'm not even
gonna make it to lunch with you yeah
is there a loaf in the freezer open
famous open face tuna sandwich at lunch
ran out of [ __ ] bread i always do it
it's either real trashy or real classy
if you get like the short
half rye like the beef steak or the beef
steak or whatever
that sounds erotic if you ask me i'll
come over your house for a beef steak
[Music]
i like it pumpernickel if you know what
i mean um
you know what is uh is real like this is
i got an opinion on this
um i only found wait hold on we didn't
finish the egg this is still the egg i
still the eggs
i'm just switching avenues over to
scrambies
um i love a good screen beat
don't you know it dude i could eat i'm
not even i'll have cheese on mine please
i'm not even [ __ ] around i could put
down a dozen scrambies for breakfast
they don't even it's like i'm eating
[ __ ] aspirin it don't even register
every time i'm making breakfast
regardless of who i'm around
when they and they're you know you know
when you when you're cooking everyone's
watching you they you know the people
[ __ ] armchair quarterback what do you
want [ __ ] top chef what do you mean
everybody's watching you
what are you living in you live in an
apartment with your wife or your
girlfriend well if i'm like down at my
one of the neighbors come up and the big
man's throwing down on brunch
i got i got two front row seats let's go
i got two in a balcony neighborhood kids
looking in the window
he's about to paint his masterpiece
they're all they always say you're
putting you'd say oh my god how many
like i'm i'm four eggs scrambling
i easy easy because it doesn't come out
to four because there's a little bit on
the edge that's such a factor
they always look smaller that's uh for
sure gotta go one extra
i do three because i do them a lot i
can't be eating [ __ ] four or five
eggs a day
they're good for you now farm fresh
cage-free
yeah whatever you need to do whatever
you need to [ __ ] tell yourself dude
um how do you make your sk all right how
i this is
how do you make your scrambies one
yeah i got a couple of questions so
don't answer until complete okay
do you mix them in a bowl first and
whisk them up
or also do you add anything to them
do you put any water or milk in them
what do you say water yeah people do
that that was a depression thing that i
found out it makes the
as my mom would say it makes it makes
the eggs go longer
jesus christ it was a depression water
yeah you milk
maybe yeah well they maybe it makes them
fluffy
it does i also know people that put some
pancake mix in there people to put a
little sour cream
all right fully who are these people
you're talking about
saporetto on the sopranos used a couple
of flowers
um all right you want to the culinary
answer is this
okay and i think i know the reason why
you're bringing this up uh not to get
too into it
um how do we do how do we do our
scrambled eggs you're not supposed to
add any salt or anything to the egg
while it's uncooked because it starts to
break down the egg you're only supposed
to season them afterwards
so what you would do is i would scramble
them up in in a bowl
i would put olive oil in the pan and
then right before i put the eggs in i
would add a little butter
you throw them in wait did you say you
do the bowl first or no scramble them up
in the bowl
okay and then and then throw them in
there and then
the trick to get great scrambled eggs is
on heat off heat
okay because it continues to cook after
you take it off the heat as everybody
knows the egg is very delicate
and it cooks very easily particularly
in high heat all right i think the
reason you're bringing this up is
because of the gordon ramsay method
which a lot of people saw on the
internet over the last couple of years
yeah i don't [ __ ] with i don't [ __ ] i
love ramsay he seems like a good [ __ ]
i don't [ __ ] with the other best
scrambled eggs i'm not saying they're
not
he does everything in a cold pot he puts
couple chunks of butter
and the whole egg in there and then
scrambles them on and off heat for
[ __ ] like
15 minutes yeah that's a long time for
scrambling oh but they come out so it
doesn't matter
so creamy a little bit of chives maybe a
little creme fresh cream cheese whatever
you got in the house
but yeah that's too long for scrambies
because you eat the scrambies in like 10
seconds
that's why you make regular scrambled
eggs to eat white starters a little
buffered
let me get a western dude let me get a
western to wait you know what party
going oh i love a western
um that was charlene thank you shaleen
classiest would be hard-boiled then
soft-boiled
um i do it on the pan i crack so i watch
this thing that's these like
french [ __ ] chefs that make like the
world's best egg or whatever at this
place out in l.a and they
crack just a little bit of butter crack
right on the pan
and then very low heat low and slow for
like you know when you just
you'll scramble them in the scramble
them in the pan i'm sure so that's the
way i go plus i don't like mixing if i
don't make i'm making dishes
if i'm scrambling in a bowl and a pan
then i got the forks dirty you got to
get another fork you can't be using that
same fork you get a bowl
you got a whole thing you know eggs are
always a weekend thing for us there was
no eggs being cooked during the week
when my dad's rushing out the door
slamming a cup of coffee my mom's
screaming at me because
you know i'm not having a shower yet
yeah it was a [ __ ] it was a
it was an imitation pop-tart called
toasters no icing
not even cooked just [ __ ] out the
door or apples and cinnamon instant
oatmeal
which was brutal yeah oatmeal can hit
the [ __ ] bricks what are you doing
what are we doing giving kids
[ __ ] chopped up cardboard get out of
here
there you go try not falling asleep in
third period fatty
you know what so as a barber load me
before
as a product of divorce uh-huh half the
week i was spent with my dad half the
week of swim with my mom
and the days of i didn't live on a bus
route like i was like in the you know
the next town over but it was like
[ __ ] seven minutes away so like the
boss would have checking a beer with a
cracked egg in it in the morning you and
your old man
[ __ ] lobe there's a beer or michelob
there's tuna in the fridge um now he was
a big he's a big wawa guy coffee guy he
doesn't make coffee at home so we would
stop at wawa everybody once they're
stopping you're you're in
dude oh your parents have to stop
somewhere to get something exploit this
[ __ ] out of it well that was breakfast
when he drove me to school we would stop
i'd get a [ __ ] wawa iced tea
and a [ __ ] bagel this is before this
they pre-date sizzling
so you get the [ __ ] bet i'd get a
bagel i hope your town has
something like a wawa and they have
something like a sizzling yes
breakfast we made breakfast sandwiches
yeah it's not too in a little floyd
uh that was chalene good stuff great
question thank you shout out kippy's not
a fan of the deviled egg
that would be my number one i don't get
it man i don't know like i just said i
grew up with some weird
you know weird food [ __ ] you know lava
[ __ ] deviled egg
um
this is one we might have talked about
this is from rob have you ever used the
kitchen stove to light a cigarette
electric or gas yeah i've [ __ ] the
electric ones man
i knew it was trashy when we were doing
it that was the only thing when we lived
in the townhouse community
uh it sounds really bad coming out of my
mouth
yeah community yeah not
the fire the fibers of that community
weren't that strong everybody was
[ __ ] everybody when they were
probably at work
but they had electric stoves and that
was the only time in my life i had to
deal with electric stuff yeah those men
[ __ ] wasn't that cool was it the coil
ones that would turn
[ __ ] bright rail but i i i knew a
couple of rich friends that had the
had the the surface yeah those things i
tried lighting bernie's all night i've
lit a bernie off one of those takes a
lot here it takes a while
dude you gotta have [ __ ] good lung
capacity but i thought those things were
like from space where it's just a plate
of glass and it heats up
those are [ __ ] tight this is how
trashy i am
i think our boy i think he listens shout
out to dougie b if you listen i know you
used to
um his family his dad worked for
whirlpool
so like when those dropped he got the
first one he had first like he got the
first one off the [ __ ] assembly line
and he put this is early 90s you know
and i remember when they got that
that like we went over to see it it was
like a thing
go over it they will see the others i
don't know holy [ __ ]
does it get any trashier than that i
don't know
if they cancel school
no homework tonight where i'll go over
to see bobby's family's oven
shout out to dougie um i remember
dougie's
dougie family whirlpool you know he
works for him you know
that's garbage
my aunt's got a new fridge to go over
and check it out to take us for a test
drive in it
here but you're outside playing in the
box
you think it's a spaceship mod can we
take it home
i'm crying oh god i literally have tears
yeah that's
holy garbage [ __ ] we went over to see
i don't know go over and see a car a
baby you don't go over to see an
appliance man
what is wrong with us what the [ __ ] was
wrong with our parents
go over and see the others hold on i
don't know if we went you go ready i got
a new pool let's go see it i don't know
if we went over a space you got to see
this washing machine it's
oh my god i don't know if you went over
yeah you did i think yeah denise wanted
to see what the joneses had going i
think it might have been we were this we
were there and we
i remember standing in the kitchen
talking about that me thinking that
thing was from [ __ ]
nasser how old were you talk what are
you a [ __ ] salesman at sears
chopping it up did you get the warranty
dude shout out to sears
oh my god that's [ __ ] great um
that's [ __ ] this is awesome this is
just a funny one i don't think do you
wait but hold on
lighting a cigarette off the electric
coils
yeah is brutal because it's
the the tobacco will stick sometimes
stick and yeah yeah yeah yeah really
yeah
those are like they they ruin the
cigarette it's life examining moments
like having a car lighter in your house
remember the old school car later who i
bought is better than cranking a [ __ ]
fresh bernie
a marlboro mild off of one of those
things because when i was a kid those
things were equal to a lightsaber as far
as
yeah mine was uh
mine would pop out like it would like
launch into like the center console
so you had to you had to have a good
[ __ ] the guy at the ford plant
when they found the spool you gotta you
had to have a good timer in your head
you know what i mean you plugged it in
you know you got about eight seconds so
that till it's [ __ ] fourth of july in
the back pushing
pushing that thing in on a cold day
[ __ ] waiting for the car to warm up
yeah oh my god that's funny as [ __ ]
and this one's from rob too it's just a
funny question do you own any clothing
with the punisher logo on it
because if you do you treach no but it
wasn't because i didn't want one i'll
tell you that when i was a kid that's
all i wanted to wear i never got into
that
you're not a comic book guy nah man well
what happened was nobody was talking
[ __ ] comics because they were like
for nerds right it was like the nerdy
kids
did comic books and like the [ __ ] all
movies and tv shows the nerd was in the
comments
you guys had a people were reading
comics you guys had like an oxy ring
when you were [ __ ] 11 years old
kind of fast and loose with the [ __ ]
perk tens
running underground casino like little
knucky thompson
yeah hey kid knew how to wet his beak
early on all right that's
www.patreon.com
are you garbage come on with us gang
[Applause]
um what was i saying yeah
oh the comic books all through the 90s
the nerd
on all media the nerd was depicted as
reading comics a comma
a comic book nerd was a thing so and
none of my friends ever talked about
like we were never like gathering comics
or we never went to go look at them
i think that's because you guys weren't
able to express your feelings
yeah well that's what i find out come
[ __ ] 2009 everybody's like i've been
watching
superman my whole life i've been reading
the comic book since i was four i'm like
why the [ __ ] did anybody tell me
i can't get into it as a [ __ ] grown
man with a receding hairline shout out
to the internet comments what did you
like that was somewhat
cutesy or child likely did you have a
doll or a teddy bear or anything i can't
believe you
[ __ ] cranking bernie's like
affectionate or like
oh yeah i didn't die of dogs growing up
you were got the rusty in patches
i'm not talking dogs like did you have a
teddy bear i had a blankie
an orange blankie that the kid loved and
this thing was
ratted tad in my [ __ ] you couldn't
put that in a wash
kid could have got my mom put in the
wash i'd stand next to the washing
machine like a
like a lost kid waiting to get picked up
uh and i had a g.i joe t-shirt that i
really liked
that i would put in the freezer and then
put on why i don't know because i was a
weird [ __ ] kid
i liked it all my nips put it in the
freezer
yeah man i was a weirdo dude well it's
just like on this like and then a hot
day
nah just you know [ __ ] around okay
just to watch my tunes
yikes that sounds real normal
how's that working out for you yeah
um holy [ __ ] yeah
what can i say dude um hmm
all right this is one this kind of goes
along with what we were talking about
this is from court how long will you
let an appliance go without
acknowledging that it doesn't work i.e
my dryer hasn't worked in two months but
we all keep pretending
it's not happening just use a laundromat
while pridefully while it privately sits
downstairs
it will remain there will remain there
we'll
and we'll pretend to be class that's
from court completely do you have any
appliances in the house or the garage
the basement that don't work
or that don't work as they should all
the time well that's i was gonna say
that's two separate questions if it's
completely broke that's one thing
but the foleys are notorious
for just cause something just because
you need a couple extra steps now to
turn it on
or to get it moving you have to do this
do that you've got to smack it you got
to jiggle the handle you got to stick
your hand in the link yeah
you got to pull the like we had a toilet
you got it you got to [ __ ] a little bit
of floor plate if you [ __ ] get your
toaster right we had a we had a toilet
that we had where we had to go in and
go into the tank almost every time you
have this dude for years
i don't i don't trust out here i don't
trust that water to this day
and i've worked for plumbing yeah tank
water you drink that nothing
clean as a whistle in that tank it
always looks so cool and clear
too is that how you keep your good skin
a little tank water
um yeah or like a lawn mower that like
the starter didn't work or
something like that whatever yeah we oh
we used to i told you we had that old
john deere
jump in cars [ __ ] in in the driveway
for a couple of months yeah
yeah that's the starter didn't work
that's time i remember one time pushing
my mom
down the street in an old dachshund
because she had a stick shift and you
know
to get her to work one day when i was
like 11 doing it
yeah that was
it's [ __ ] that's one step above fred
flintstone
hey hey booboo henry get up and give me
a push
oh jesus christ that's bad um
we had a tractor that i had to jump
every time with like the portable
battery to turn it on
yeah yeah because they're like
especially like completely broke
you're jeff foxworthy at that point you
got to get that out of there yeah
yeah yeah i mean there's i'm trying to
think i mean there's definitely
yeah we got a garage full of just
[ __ ] [ __ ] from the 90s left over
that doesn't work there's a little
there's a little go-kart in there with
four flat tires that doesn't run ooh
we should break that out i thought i
mean i could nobody could no groan it
was for like a [ __ ]
it was for like a six-year-old it's like
tiny oh really yeah yeah i wouldn't fit
it could be funny you know what else is
real trashy which i've done a bunch
um is the slow leak in the tire that you
keep the air compressor in the trunk for
and then you're at like [ __ ] super
fresh parking lot blowing up your thing
smoking a bernie
all through my 20s i had a honda accord
that almost every
other time that i got gas i had to get
oil because i had some kind of slow oil
leak
always yeah you were always if you're
like yeah
for sure i still run on the edge a
little bit your car is [ __ ]
man that thing what what what it's nice
what do it stinks it's nice on the
inside
it's a new york city car man it's got
some it's got some dings on it that rust
on the wheels from the whoa
hey oh what the [ __ ]
jesus christ kelly blue book on that
thing still tip top
you bought it how you saw it this was
another one hold on i want to find
this is from uh renee shout out to renee
this while we're on the subject
what is in your cup holders in your car
right now
or the door holders too that's yours
yours are either
nice for like two days or because i do
get the car washed every couple
couple of weeks i'll give you that yeah
but sometimes you get you sometimes you
get in there and it's like a [ __ ]
rat's nest but that's what
that's why i love my car so much is
having that
like you know it feels like it's my
space i love when it's like
when it has like my things all spread
out around it like i'm a big
i'm a big guy that or when when i get
into the car i love putting all my [ __ ]
on the passenger seat big passing i feel
like i feel like michael j
fox and [ __ ] uh back to the future
that's honestly why i do it that's a
true story that's why i do it
um like you know putting like your
smokes in your phone and everything's
right there however you think it's like
a cool thing like that's why i do it
you're
most americans put their stuff on their
[ __ ] hands i think it is cool it's
like one of the charms of having
having a car that's why i love my little
my little car
okay but i can say this
as time goes on one thing you will
definitely find
in most crevices of my car french fries
no that's pretty big in my mom's sebring
a couple of [ __ ] bk fries snuck down
there couldn't get him with the tweezer
face mickey these fries don't age well
i'll tell you that they do not age well
no
i will always have a crumpled up straw
wrapper
uh they hang around for a while water
bottles too
a lot of trouble they'll be like a
little rim of like tobacco
not burnt tobacco but like that shakes
yeah
a cough drop or two i left quarters
i let my car sit for a little bit uh
and when i got back in there to get the
quarters out i had to get like a [ __ ]
jackhammer to [ __ ] really get them
out
gross they were in there with like soda
and [ __ ] everything sweating you know
[ __ ] was [ __ ] in there i did that
this summer when i had when i did a
really deep clean on the car i scooped
out all my quarters i had to put them in
like a little bucket with like soapy
water and like
like let them sit overnight just [ __ ]
toss them give them to homeless guys i
throw out money
okay now all of a sudden you've been
[ __ ] johnny lawless no it's bad karma
bad karma i've never heard that yeah you
throw out money and money goes away from
you
it's like a penny on head listen i can't
run away from you any quicker okay
uh great question there's always an
empty soda cup in there too
oh yeah i'm the same way which i'm
surprised you guys don't bust me more
for my
fast food intake because there's usually
uh i should i mean i should own you
constantly the fans say i'm too mean to
you you're
you consume way too much fast food
because the other day i had a
i had a little milkshake thing in there
and there was some milkshake on the seat
and you got in and didn't notice it
i'm trying to be nicer to you i did
notice it
first of all i thought it was calm and
then i saw the [ __ ] milkshake thing
in the in the cup holder whacking off in
the car i
think i got a little frisque
um i'm trying to find this one because
we were talking about cars um
here it is this is from dennis have you
ever owned two of the same cars
one to drive and one for parts holy [ __ ]
what no well let me tell you about
2 so
my brother had a chevy lumina
right at one point quit bragging i know
not i'm not bragging my brother
got a really cheap pose of chevy lumina
so he had that i
also my stepdad my first car was for
like 1200 bucks i think when he bought
me a chevy were you two both driving
around the same model car
different colors but yeah i had a white
heel like a that like 90s
that early 90s [ __ ] militia blue
you know that like light blue yeah yeah
that's what his was
the luminous stunk all right it was no
there was no straight angles on it
it was all bent it was awful it was all
curves yeah
yeah that car when it was like oddly
wide on the inside it was big that was a
big bottle a big bench seat in the front
weird yeah you could like dude you could
lay in that thing top like
head to toe there was something else
that came around the same time like
that's what they advertised it was like
real
wide like it was like a caprice classic
type thing yeah but bigger
but so i had mine i had a white one my
brother had a blue one
i think my brother went to college and
his car was just like sitting at the
house you know what i mean because he
was like living in the city or whatever
right so i had mine i then crashed mine
around a telephone pole
on my block while i was cutting school
right
so we just took that my stuff that put
it at a shop that he has
so that was at the shop and he replaced
it with the same exact car for 1200
bucks
he found the same exact car uh-huh and i
just got a
1995 white chevy lumina so now
you know it's like 2004 that car your
step dad did this
yeah he had to buy it for you yeah he
probably hated you oh
yeah i would have kicked you to the
[ __ ] curb so
i would have kept your sister and your
brother yeah they're good shits yeah you
would have been [ __ ] out
stuff i look at you just about a
liability be losing my heart on as i'm
walking into my
room what the [ __ ] dude
and people say i'm too mean to you i was
[ __ ] talking about
kevin go and you treehouse in a while
yeah um
[ __ ] weird fat kid staring at me
a little blonde bowl cup go play with
the dog will you
sweatpants too tight um but then my
lumina
miner roll my ten-year-old chevy loom
kept breaking down
but we had my brother's car and my
broken
and the one that i crashed sitting so we
were just it was this thing was like
frankenstein we were just harvesting
them for parts
different color bodywork is real bad
when you see a guy that has like a
different
colored like trunk but i respect it
because it's all intentions i've already
i'll get it i'll get it on there and
then i'll paint it next week because
they're jammed up for cash i've
been not painting anything they think
they think they're going to
but then the laziness to take you know
where do you go and get your whole can
mako double a mco it never looks like
the finish is never
never as brilliant yeah well it's better
than a [ __ ] red hood on a phone
call always seemed garbage it was like
4.99 i don't know what they're doing how
was their advertising budget they were
on like
every [ __ ] third commercial was mako
i know
yeah some dirt bag [ __ ] kind of dui
in this [ __ ] iroc z
i need some dings banged out this one
this one this is also from dennis dennis
had a couple of [ __ ] home runs
um have you ever owned a plastic garden
shed
oh we have one next to our garage right
now yeah it's got
it's got the snow blower in it and a
bunch of wasp nests and scary spiders
yeah tell you that those things my mom
always can you run i get the [ __ ] out of
here those things only look good till
the first time it rains or a hot summer
do they start [ __ ] fading
i look like a bad playhouse i had to
clean the outside of it today it was all
like it ain't
no i mean this summer it was all like
green you know like that like green moss
starts growing up on it yeah
that's the grass clippings that are
stuck to the side of it and [ __ ] yeah
there's always a [ __ ]
killer spider in there too running the
running the block yeah
oh man they don't [ __ ] two flies just
like
it's a [ __ ] those things don't dude
those things
only they look good when you get them
that's one of those things that's like
it looks great and you're like oh this
is awesome and then they
they they [ __ ] unless you unless you
got a you got a maintenance program on
those things
i always thought sheds were pretty
trashy too yeah this is i've
done better with them and my brother has
a real nice one like i would live in it
yeah some of them are nice he's got that
gasoline smell i'll put you right to
sleep
uh we had a shed that never finished it
was just the foundation of the shed in
the backyard looks like a manger
no it's just this baby kippy it was just
like a big square on the ground the
floor was laid but nothing else
that's true we were trash dude that's
bad if you lay the foundation to walk
away from the job
man that's bad especially when the job's
in your backyard that's no
good yeah uh
so yes yeah i do have one that's bad it
has a moon roof too it actually opens up
on top
so you can check the stars out while
you're cooking beans
oh god that is good um
hmm oh this is matt my questions are you
garbage you frequent a gas station for
your lunch such as
wawa i've had breakfast there most of my
childhood so yeah
it's tough um but some of them stepped
their game up some of them got decent
food but
you can't be gone it's all right if
you're in a pinch if you're driving if
you don't have much time but
if you're going every day to it's you
know people in the burbs man
most of them have that morning routine
my mom had that
every single good morning routine
[ __ ] getting in the car hit getting
your coffee getting your whatever
and driving to work i would go get i'd
[ __ ] go
to wawa get a sizzli a hash brown
if i was you know treating myself a
little bit [ __ ] wawa iced tea this is
when i was working like
when i first started doing comedy i was
working in the city i'd have to [ __ ]
get up
crush that in the parking lot wouldn't
even make it i'd [ __ ]
[ __ ] rip right through that you know
i love eating and driving
you can't enjoy it it's too much i
[ __ ] crush this that's part of it
crush the scissor and then [ __ ] i'll
have a bernie lit before i even pulled
out of the [ __ ] parking lot
take that first sip of my extra extra
coffee good night how's that breath when
you get into the office man
right to the crapper no no bueno
this is one um oh and in the other sense
have you ever used the microwave frozen
food at a gas them have you ever used
the microwave at like the 7-eleven or
something
let me tell you something it's funny you
mentioned that because i thought about
this the other day that's from ray
ray that's great that's a true i can't
believe we haven't talked about that yet
you know i'm 10 years older than you
right are you yeah okay so
this is like pre-wawa or whatever
7-eleven have like a fruit they had
like the frozen hamburgers and they had
the frozen burrito was like
it was like part of pop culture in you
know in the early 80s like you know
going to the center and get a burrito
i never could cross that [ __ ] bridge
they just looked
so dirty and so gross especially those
this is
80s frozen hamburgers now i've had a
hamburger
from 7-eleven in the past five years
because i would say past five days but
whatever
whatever you want to tell yourself big
man well they started to put the you
know the hot box in the front at
7-eleven they got the wings in there and
then they got the
the pizza warmer sometimes they those
are all right i mean i've
i'm on the record for saying this
anytime you pull off those [ __ ]
those heat lamps well they throw me the
[ __ ] off they throw cheeseburgers in
there and they're in like a little foil
bag
the buns [ __ ] moist they're i tell
you what for a walking around burger
they ain't too shabby get you out of a
pinch oh yeah they'll [ __ ] straighten
you out that's a slurpee get your head
off
all right let me get let me get a burger
and a slur and a coca-cola slurping
[ __ ]
let me start thinking clear my head a
little bit
i gotta get some fresh air in here you
know what i mean um
but the frozen ones nah dude i like that
i think i used it once or twice and i
got it i
i don't understand i just always thought
that it seems too commercial for me it
seems like you got to have the guy come
do it for you
it's stainless steel it's got like two
buttons i'm like i
i never wasn't trained on this is the
sous chef available
i'm like dude i don't know this this
don't look like the one in my house
where's the easy minute button
i don't think they allow you to do that
anymore there's no microwaves in
7-elevens anymore
i think there is no i thought there had
to have been a lawsuit
because those were industrial that's
what i'm saying i always thought i'm
like i never write anything
down i know never because those things
were hot especially in the 90s
they come out steaming we were never a
sev family
we we never went to se we were both they
were 7-eleven is trashier than wawa for
sure
sure just dirtier they're dingier
everything's got grease on it but
they're more national
and their chili sauce ain't too shabby
shout out to seven yeah
well on the wow okay this is also from
dennis then it's got three home runs
microwaving food on a paper what's this
guy paying you off
now we're going to be getting emails
www.patreon well they they're coming up
naturally
this is microwaving food on a paper
towel to save from washing a plate
yeah for sure i can use that as my
pillowcase also i'm
real weird about i like conserving paper
towels though
no not me i'm an animal love it uh yeah
i don't know that's why i got in the
game
i'm telling you what's what i'm ruthless
when it comes to paper towels i can
imagine
um and if it was socially acceptable i'd
probably wipe my butt with a paper towel
because you get a little more grip
oh yeah it's just a little tough if you
have if you if you go to the well a
couple too many times you're going to be
[ __ ] but if you get those
screams staying too bad all right here
we go here we go here we go
this is from richie is it classy or
trashy to use wet wipes aka baby wipes
after you poop
richie thinks it's classy nice clean
feel
i say that it's trashy because i'm on
the fence about this i just think
they're gross as a whole but that just
could be that just could be
because of my situation obviously my
situation back there ain't good
all right there's a lot of construction
that needs to go on there's a lot of
twists and a lot of turning
i got to do a lot to to keep that area
you know
which i would think the code i think i
think the wipes would help you know
it did too much moisture maybe there's
two it's like it's like your ass is wet
after you after you get done doing it
and like it has the
none of them have like that good smell
and on an adult it just smells like
baby [ __ ] on an adult that's what it
makes me think of i gotcha i gotcha from
you come out with some you know
different flavors basil
wait i think are you eating them no but
they all just have that distinct like
baby yeah but they have them now
that are like you know they go aloe
that's the best they do aloe vera yeah
they do
it i want something there's like the man
white let's see look at your car
you know something like ck1 obsession
smelling this is gross by foley
yeah um you know what the other day
i don't stock it i get like i've done it
in the past
well she uses it i don't think i think
it's so i think it's okay
i don't know like i don't think it's for
fat guys let me put it to you that way i
think it would be for fact but that's
just me i don't i need to make a fat
guy's brand
they do char one time char one wife
charlie's oh really well they're not a
sponsor but yeah
what are you a marine in the 40s one way
journalist
jesus christ keep a pc will you but the
other day
it's funny to answer that question
because it made me think of it i there
was no toilet paper
so i had to use wet wipes for the whole
process that's not good no you got a tp
and then
the the jet stream it with the wet wipe
yeah yeah i had to do i had to do oh
[ __ ] scene man you got a shower
that's too much dude that is that's what
i'm saying
somebody chimed in in the chat dude
wipes that's what they're called dude
wipes thank you
um this is uh dan from manchester in it
in england uh in england when it's nice
when it's nice weather all the pubs
with beer gardens outdoor drinking areas
are ridiculously busy and it's tough to
get served
so i check what bottled beer they sell
and go buy the beers at a liquor store
and then sit there and enjoy the beer
in the garden with the genuine customers
is this merely troubleshooting or am i
garbage
oh you're [ __ ] a dirt bag what do you
mean
ah no good
i don't service is never that bad
how does that is the waiter a packed bar
when was the last time you were
like a packed [ __ ] bar how does the
server
they don't have servers or you go up to
the pub and buy it the thing
oh uh i mean it's functional you're
there for
uh booze is a little weird what if
everybody did that hippie what if
everybody did that i'm not saying it's
right
i'm saying i understand kippy likes this
i don't know what you do when you're
over there in europa
with your high falutin wife out there
[ __ ] i know you two like to hit beer
gardens and hobnob
yeah for all i know you're ripping off
some port tavern owner in [ __ ]
hospital
even no i love supporting small business
i like to support but also at the same
time i get this guy
now maybe if you do a one-for-one you
buy one have your own buy one have your
own maybe is the order in food
at least come on you're ripping the
place off i get it as a server
at the same time i want to [ __ ] drink
i like kip
i drink your house man i drink them fast
i do what i i'm not i'm not saying i do
this but i
that's not that's not our kind of
garbage it's not a class move no
definitely not class no it's sneaking
liquor into a place is a trashy move
sure i do it i i don't do it i've done
it
i want um but you're not that big of a
boozer either
you know stick a couple other things
into the bar though
check the bathroom situation [ __ ]
booth in advil
um it's so sad my head always goes there
when i go into a restaurant or bar
i scope out see what the bathroom
situation's like yeah my buddies
uh wanted to make an app a coke for
coke-friendly bathrooms in the city
how great is that ski bumps it's a ski
bumps app that's terrible
um but yeah it's definitely not a classy
move
i think it depends maybe you know yeah
no good stop doing that my friend
nah do it from time to time how can you
say that
that'd be like if you went into a
restaurant and brought your own food and
sat there it's completely different
how you're not buying the product at the
place
because you don't consume [ __ ] 15
chicken parm entrees at a time it's not
it's not a it's a volume thing it's a
time and volume thing
i don't know if if i had sometimes i
don't know who you are
what do you mean i don't know well
you're getting up i'm not saying it's
not a [ __ ] he's also not stealing
from them
technically he is he's taking up to he's
taking up table where where people would
spend money
outside you stand in the streets and
stuff oh oh maybe i'm missing or like
you stan it's not
like i don't know he's not taking up a
table or something he's just hanging out
i only
and also he's probably with a group of
people who are drinking i don't think
he's sneaking in a sixer and standing in
the corner like a weirdo
okay maybe he is i don't know danny well
not that but i'm saying if you're taking
up a table where paying customers would
be or something like that that's correct
no it's not like a first
okay it's not a burn internal thing you
go to the bar and then go sit at your
place you go up to the bar go sit at
your place i got you
if the the bar is [ __ ] 30 deep and
you're hanging out having a good time
you need your [ __ ] pop that's all i'm
saying in that case sure
i don't agree with it but you know it's
you know it's definitely not the worst
thing in the world
you're trash is that what you want me to
say dan you're trash
definitely but i respect it from time to
time yeah but once
one's much different than the other um
yeah all right this is from ryan this is
i don't know if we talked about this is
the one i've been wanting to bring up
for a while
what type of sandwich bags did you use
did you use the ziploc
or the flap the foldis
family too come on yeah by the time i
got the [ __ ] lunch my [ __ ]
nibblers were all over the bottom of my
bag what the [ __ ] mom
[ __ ] goldfish leaking out all over my
school bag those things couldn't keep a
peanut butter and jelly protected to
save their life
i remember thinking as a [ __ ]
six-year-old at lunch going how do
this tech this isn't even technology
none of this works
i don't get it i'll tell you what it's
better than though better off putting
rubber bands around oh you know it was
real trashy when the kid would [ __ ]
reach into his uh his brown paper bag
and pull out something wrapped in tin
foil oh like what the [ __ ]
what does your mom do what's the deal
what's coming out of that
sammy and tin foil ain't bad though
that's true
as a little no you know what the real
trash is just cellophane
if you got like a [ __ ] ham sandwich
wrapped in just elephants
it's like it's like molded around the
coke can of coke or whatever
oh [ __ ] my mom used to do that she would
wrap the soda in a
and tin foil thinking that keeps it cold
that was big in the 90s
i think it might still do that i don't
know that didn't do anything
yeah that's [ __ ] silver bullets
that's trash yeah uh yeah we were all
cellophane or all
uh all folks the rolled ups yeah i i
i'm that's all we were and i'm so garb
like those things are
ingrained in me that if i
when i do this now it wouldn't even fit
in one of those things
i go straight tupperware put in a pot
i have to put it in a guitar case
i got a four footer in there
like a dust killed on instead of a
machine gun
hey what are you going to a concert now
lunch oh my god i've got a briefcase
just for my sandwich
somebody just sat in the chat kippy
looks like one of those guys in the
theater that carries the girls around so
it makes it look like they're flying
stagehand kippy
working the lion king a little bit more
of a turtleneck and you're spot on
oh dude [ __ ] bald man shout out to
cody or i don't know king biscuits
that's a [ __ ] home run
holy [ __ ] that's funny
but when i buy ziploc bags now i think
i'm spending too much money because we
were such a non-zip block fam
i go i go i'm getting the good ones i'm
like this is i'm always getting the good
ones i don't have kids
that's what it's all about that's one
thing i love about [ __ ] uh
you know about you know where we came
from and
and just the just the tupperware
cellophane all that that whole
industry's evolution
it's fantastic now i get the big [ __ ]
ziploc bags
and put like you know like things in
there oh that's i use that [ __ ] as
luggage yeah me too
those things are great dude we were
moving i got a box of those i was just
throwing [ __ ] in there
you know what my mom does now i don't
know why she does it
okay but instead of carrying like her
little wallet or a purse
she puts her cards and
a ziploc bag and receipt in a ziploc she
going to the [ __ ] water park
who does that i don't know why she did
it all summer
that's a beach thing that's a beach and
water park she wasn't there no beach
yeah it's cause she's trash just by the
pool in case someone throws me to the
pool
i need to protect my cell phone i still
make your favorites
trash too have you ever thrown your mom
in a pool fully clothed that was big in
the night
throwing someone in a pool they're like
holding onto the fence and [ __ ]
i got my phone i got my phone
[Laughter]
ah nothing better than that [ __ ] oh man
that's funny
yeah i don't know why she does it all i
know why
she's trash all ziploc all day
i don't think any first ladies are
putting their [ __ ] [ __ ] in a ziploc
bag
in case they get thrown in a pool holy
[ __ ]
this is a big uh we only got a cup oh
[ __ ] a couple of minutes let me get it
wrap it up i love these oh man these are
so much fun our [ __ ] what's cooking
in the chat
uh what else we got i don't know um
i'm not thinking it's i mean you know
there's a whole bunch of people in there
chatting it up okay yeah i mean i can't
the third
you know moving on with the segment
thank you um
yes and ryan over here well i don't know
i mean i'm trying to read that question
you're like well what's going on in the
chat let me start throwing you
curveballs
hit me how much do you weigh uh will you
eat peanut butter straight out of the
jar
i wish i liked it more i i'm not a pb
guy i
i wish i liked it more i do do it
but i wish i liked it more you wish you
liked peanut butter more
i wish i liked doing that more i do it
but i don't
i don't love it i'm usually i like to
stick a a
a hershey bar in there or some celery so
if i get to
talk about the duality of man a
different hershey bar or a [ __ ] piece
of salt or a piece of apple or something
like that
you know what's big i'm just the [ __ ]
are that big fan of just a big spoon of
[ __ ]
chunky yeah just no not chunky i'm a
creamy family well
i think you have an opinion on this and
i don't know
break down the [ __ ] how you feel the
brands of peanut butter are
um because i want to come out and say i
was a skippy household yeah that's
i think skippy would have been the
premium brand
i think as we were growing up yeah what
about jiff
yeah they're okay okay gif seems more
like a family-owned business to me
skippy was like new money i feel skippy
was real creamy
i'll tell you that they [ __ ] there
was like an inch of oil at the top when
you open that thing
yeah um we were peter pan for a while
that's not bad all right peter pan we
were never we were never
we certainly never did like smucker's
natural or anything like you know real
peanut butter [ __ ] no
that was not perfected when i was a kid
and a follow-up question regardless in
there
regarding pb
oyster shells like one of those bars
where you can crack [ __ ]
the peanuts and just keep dropping uh
do you would uh would you spring for the
little jar or the big jar
come on we're making she's cranking out
she's like a [ __ ]
you know i don't know what you're gonna
say but there's only two kids so it
should be two sandwiches
she was making sandwiches all right she
she needed the [ __ ] family we were
all family size everything
you gotta figure two sandwiches a day
usually two sandwich per
kid at a certain point yeah i wasn't
going to school with [ __ ] one peanut
butter and jelly like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
not in [ __ ] like you know middle
school in high school dude i had [ __ ]
two pb and jays and
she knew send me prepared yeah because
otherwise
i just eat more when i come home and
she's not there like getting to the
pantry i told you that i would like a
grizzly i would do a [ __ ] can of slim
fast
and hers pretzel nibblers that was my
after that was my snack when i got
that's how fat i like it
i just thought it was like chocolate how
did the divorce go i thought it was
chocolate milk
dude where do you dental hygienist milk
and pretzels i get down on the salty and
the sweet
see all right there you go wow look at
you
turning a little bit you just have to go
a little bit further with that
then you've got a nice nice chicken milk
is sweet
that's why salty things go good with it
yeah but not [ __ ] meat
pretzels are different maybe that's
that's just a little bit above a
bowl of cereal if you ask me
that's like [ __ ] special k [ __ ]
pretzels and cereal
come on i always thought about that
everything's real close to being cereal
you know what you know what was a
[ __ ] a mind blower it's still like i
can taste how
sweet it was we made cereal from teddy
grahams
oh yeah we did it sucks because that box
was so small so it was really only like
a [ __ ]
one bowl they lasted about 12 seconds
they were like
they were like they folded
yeah because we used to do that with uh
with uh graham crackers i would do that
or i would sprinkle some graham crackers
on top of my uh rice crisp
that's what your family got graham
covering our rice krispies
how are you name brand graham crackers
because there's a significant difference
between
graham cracker like nabisco graham
crackers or whatever it was and the
generic ones
because we were typically a generic
family we were never a traditional
graham cracker family
we were never a traditional graham
cracker family what my mom got was in
the bisco dark box
that had cinnamon and sugar coated on
top of the of the graham cracker
that's what we got i don't know what
they're called but they were sparkling
and when you take some counter butter
and slather it on one of those things
and a [ __ ] cold glass of milk while
you're standing there watching [ __ ]
married with children on a sunday night
the endorphins were popping um
all right let's see here we'll do one or
two more and wrap it up
this has been shoe fun um
this is one that i just saw on the way
over here that's like oh you only see
trashy people doing it is carrying
carrying around a bluetooth speaker
playing music out loud dude what are we
doing dude
what the [ __ ] are we doing we were
talking about this the other night i
always assume
people that do that people that like rap
out loud on the subway or walk down the
street like
singing or rapping really loud that they
have a gun on them or they know
some form of martial arts karate have a
knife on them
that they're ready to fight because you
don't act like that
unless you got nothing to lose you know
what i mean
that [ __ ] is so [ __ ] crazy to me who
the [ __ ]
unless every once in a while when
someone's rolling down and they get
they're playing something hots and it's
setting the scene on the street
that ain't too big it's a little
different very few and far between yeah
if you're
it's i think it's different if you're
hanging if you're posted up
that's fine like if you're like hey i'm
hanging on the corner we're having a
beer we're playing whatever
like if you're chilling i'm fine with
that but if you're like on the subway
what have you ever done that stunt on
the corner what is this do the right
thing i'm not saying i am okay but it's
just new york instead of people sitting
in people's apartments to go
[ __ ] hang on you know on this stoop
but they're they're
set up they're hanging out there they're
smoking a cig listening to music
whatever i can
i just pictured you like in the
cul-de-sac with like the boombox
trying to pretend like you were in
brooklyn and how come we don't even talk
no more
who may get a tall drink of water just
walked in the boss is here
um but i saw a guy going
in and out of [ __ ] mcdonald's today
and i'm like you're just annoying
at any given point you're annoying 30
people yeah it's insane
[ __ ] wrap it up nobody does that
unless
they know somebody might they're looking
for somebody to say something they're
looking for some sort of attention of
course
yeah exactly that [ __ ] drives me nuts
i've always i've asked female friends of
mine that
if you know this is kind of a new york
thing but if you were if you were dating
a guy
and then one day like i mean just like
you know dating like not i'm listening
not in a serious relationship you were
dating a guy
and you were on the subway going to work
one day or something like that and you
saw him
on the subway and he was like rapping
out loud with his headphones on
or doing something like that would you
then break up with
i would oh god it means you're a psycho
yeah it's crazy it is like looking in
they look at their reflection and
they're like do they you know
rap and it's the same thing like the
guy's handing out their mixtape or
you're doing the [ __ ] air guitar or
something like doing the frets like as
though you're listening to this
oh you're just like being into it yeah
[ __ ] g chord f
g chord it's like dude you're not
fooling anybody okay
[ __ ] eddie van halen relax like
you're gonna get discovered on the
subway yeah like oh this guy knows a
[ __ ] power chord check him out easy
yeah [ __ ] loserville
welcome yeah guys that's it for us we're
yeah just hit the hour guys thank you so
much we appreciate it thank you
everybody that [ __ ] wrote in
yep um as always please make sure you
rate if you subscribe on itunes that'll
keep us pump us up in the charts and
yeah in the rankings we appreciate it
we need your love and support more than
more than ever yeah we're out on an
island right now
gentlemen and we need the life support
pushing off just yeah wilson
i appreciate that uh as always and we're
going to continue to do
you know this is our third family
episode third floor yeah we're gonna be
we're gonna obvious everybody seems to
be loving these
they write in it you know these are some
of their favorite episodes and stuff
like that so we appreciate that
we're gonna keep doing them 100 um yeah
you can check us out at matrion.com
everything and uh yeah guys thank you so
i want to thank gas for sure
as corny as it sounds uh from the bottom
of our hearts and they
you know it's an awesome family here gas
is fantastic we appreciate all the
support from ralph
100 the whole production team bobby
hutch everything has been fantastic and
not that you're not gonna because i know
you are because you found us through gas
digital is please keep supporting gas
digital in everything that they do what
they do is
is super important as far as uh as far
as comedy is concerned i feel
um so please keep supporting them
support us
we love you guys we're all trying our
best for you to to make everybody uh
happy and uh and we love this so much
and dylan thank you so much for
everything my friend
dylan mike thank you so much we
appreciate it and uh that's it we'll be
back with a new episode and we'll be
we'll be
we'll be cooking and booking baby yeah
buddy we love you and we'll see you guys
soon